hello everybody and welcome to let's
play cry of fear okay this is one that a
lot of people suggested as well and when
I heard that was a half-life 1 mod I
assumed it was old but this game was
just released like February 20th of this
year so it's very new I'm pretty excited
to play it I've heard it's like
terrifying out of your mind
so it's by the same people I think that
made afraid of monsters is another mod
that people have been suggesting so ok
easy medium or difficult now they're
meeting right in all right there we go
ok I'm gonna be quieter through the
cutscenes in this game so you can know
what's going on because I'm I imagine a
lot of you don't know anything about
this I've always felt alone
my whole life for as long as I can
remember I don't know if I like getting
hurt or if I'm just used to it
but I do know this being lonely he does
things to you feeling [ __ ] bitter and
angry all the time just
it's the way at you
that's good so far all right
hello kitty
that's pretty darn good for a half-life
one I mean no kidding they must have
made some custom improvements definitely
the lighting system I bet so good for
them how many people working with a
half-life 1 ended anymore in fact I
doubt hardly anyone is was probably the
only one that's been made for a long
time
I'm not sure where this is taking place
judging by the names obviously a
European country
oh yeah that lighting conditioning
changed
is a dark and stormy night quite fitting
because actually where I am right now
it's a dark and stormy night so cry of
fear
okay
oh yeah a lot of love was put into this
game I could tell because the character
actually has depth to his face I
remember I played a lot of half-life 1
months back
the early two-thousands a lot of them I
kept up with Planet half-life and all
the mod sources so I know a good
half-life mod when I see one and this is
exceptional quality yeah that that looks
like a half-life 2 mod lost a good is
because it almost looks like the texture
so I'll have bug max Oh somebody oh [ __ ]
Oh animated what happened rinses
what happened what happened sir
oh oh oh no oh okay the guy on the
ground was in on it he just wanted to
get run over as well okay
oh hello yeah ugly pad itself kind of
like nightmare oh wow you are so ugly
man what the hell hey stop that wake up
I'm already awake oh whoa oh
take the camera all right I'll do what
you say man
that was the main character I thought oh
hello I got a camera ah
rabbi hey half life 2 pink dress ah yeah
clicky clicky slash I like it God like
certain numbers I don't see a a ammo
counter so I'm guessing hey whoa hello
Seth yeah
oh okay so I flashed the edges can't see
anything I hate you well fu buddy Oh
door dark so dark creepy ah the dead
body the odd gun oh man this is creepy
ha ha ha ha Voges in face oh goodness
ah broken window oh man
oh so creepy oh hi get out here Oh seven
years bad luck for you ah I can't take
this anymore
no kidding man oh let's go be so far
away
huh huh ah no one okay okay oh that
terrified me oh man where am i oh man
where are you man all the hurt feel on
my chest I get here I don't care man get
out of here okay no phone credit as
usual I better get out of here okay that
sounds like a good idea it's getting
dark oh that scared the crap out of me
whoa oh I got a knife lost in a city all
right oh man
that ought to switch modes all right
um yeah I'll go with the other buddy man
I'm not joking that was one of the
scariest thing I've ever seen was this
pixel left there we go okay can I come
do a wheel phone and I don't know the
phone where are you come home as soon as
possible it's getting dark
yes mama oh really
my phone is my flashlight well I guess
it's I guess it's 2012 that makes sense
ah I saw that no no no no no come in I
got a knife oh good yeah you stay out of
my way
find a code to the padlock okay
man this okay I usually I expect doors
to have handles if I can open them but
whoo this game is off to a good start I
mean I mean he was just a jump-scare but
I haven't been jumpscared like that in
all the games I've played seriously what
was it I'd be nice be happy I got a
knife back off back off okay whoo all
right ha ha ha actually I'm gonna cut it
here thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you're enjoying let's play oh man
this is off to a good start
I can tell this is gonna be a fantastic
game so stick around and I will see you
in the next part
bye bye